I realized that a belief system was
actually a set of moral guidelines
and moral guidelines are guidelines
about how you should behave.
Also,
how you should perceive,
and the reason that a moral guideline is
necessary for you to perceive is that
you can't look at anything without a
hierarchy of value,
right?
Think about it like how many things in
this room could you look out?
There's an in innumerable things in this
room to look at.
There's just all this squares,
the little tiny squares in this fabric.
You could look at those things for till
the end of time,
one at a time,
but you don't do that.
In fact,
if I took most of you out of this room,
there's a very low probability that
you'll be,
you'd be able to tell me what color the
walls were,
or even if those things were on the
walls.
And the reason for that is that who
cares?
As long as the walls don't move,
colors irrelevant,
and there's no reason for you to
remember it.
It has no emotional significance.
It has no value.
And so what you do instead is,
well,
this is what you're doing.
So why are you here?
Do I don't mean in the broad
metaphysical sense?
I mean specifically,
why are you here right now?
And I would say,
well,
you're a students obviously and you're
trying to get a degree and you know,
you believe that that will have some
functional utility.
Maybe you'll be a little wiser and a
little more literate and a little and be
able to think a little better and be
able to write a little better.
And so you'll actually be more
functional in the world.
That would be good.
You know,
and,
and maybe you're interested in,
but anyways,
it's,
you're in this particular lecture so
that you can take this particular class
so that you can get a particular kind of
degree so that you can launch your life.
And then in your life you're probably
going to meet someone that you have a
longterm relationship with and you're
going to have children and you're going
to partake in the society.
And that's why you're here.
All of those reasons simultaneously is
why you're here.
And so then that helps you decide what
to look at.
And so what you look at is at the
moment,
or listen to is me,
because in principle,
I'm the gateway to that set of
accomplishments at this moment.
And so you focus on me and that's
because you value that.
And so what that means.